from the instant so close study
visionary corresponds to a phase of
libyan project schumann and led
they saw each other little but after this period
when monet plan commissioner havel
work in liaison with the prime
minister mr week the current of
trust passed between them they were
visionaries  in all areas he
had, for example, he often told me
the idea that I said earlier
in the film the eastern countries will
return again to the bosom of europe on the
9th  May 50 I lived it in my newsroom
because no journalist outside of Paris
could attend it it was
improvised it is so true that the
photographers have theirs we had
forgotten them when I saw with my editor
in  head of the nets the first sentences
but that's exactly the answer to the
questions that robert shuman was asking
nine months earlier that was the answer
live restigouche equal treatment yes
nab and you saw that in a winner
in vai  ncu in history as well as
mines at chipmunks of de schumann
declarations and nadine fifty and stadium i
was the first time date of dream could
be implemented it was necessary to convince
public opinion and public opinion
that it was the end of  the war the
discovery of the concentration camps
it was the horror of the war
each one had lived on his side and all
of a sudden there are a certain number
of men coming from six different countries
where there are victors and vanquished
who come to explain to you and well
now we are going to work together
it was extraordinarily difficult I
tell you this to the young people today
because I believe that from time to time in the
end you say to yourself there is
only to do this  we don't see it well,
etc.
it's no longer the same
situation but they were badly taken,
you know they were very criticized
now, on the other hand, I believe that
as young people we must remember
everything that is in the process of  to be said here
precisely p  in relation to peace
because often when we discuss for me
when I discuss with friends or what
it is often on the principle
that europe the goal of europe was
just a commercial project with
coal  tata steel and we forget
precisely if of the two peace which is at
the origin and I think which is very
important and which gives a kind of
breath of humanism which does a lot of
good and which will do us a lot of good
I think of everyone today  today it's an
idea of jean monnet he always struc
me who helped me a lot in my life we do
't do anything it's individuals without ind
viduals nothing changes but nothing
lasts if we don't have one
institution of bretton woods project and
immigration that ten dates lips i need
you down on had i believe that the
challenge immigration is a very important challenge
the european union must evolve the will
crystallize in its current form
i think it is necessary  a strong core i
believe it deep
manas batter at 10 join t  a little earlier
are his point of view but there
are positive points that
we must insist on majan see I see
several exchanges erasmus for
example schumann dreamed of that it would
really welcome because he thought that
maybe we should have
continued europe calls bull coal-steel
by culture before asking
aubin mavericks hearing you talk about
the fathers of europe
one gets the impression that they had a
vision and that they  were very close
to citizens in their way of
conducting politics and now we young people
often think yes these people
no longer exist do you see
politicians who have this same vision
your luck
came out yesterday it was precisely to have
politicians who have offered us
perspectives europe it is also in your hands
that this meeting is
an opportunity for you to become
even more aware of it than you had when you entered
and show the in your life that  otidienne
no she's going to die here you have my
father said we to see if there are
nationalized political
individualities piss them and in libya